[Musique]
mes chers compatriotes de métropole de
l'outre-mer et de l'étranger
la crise sanitaire que nous traversons
cette épidémie de covin 19 dure depuis
maintenant plus d'un an un an de peine
des preuves vous nous aurons été au
moins quatre millions et demi a
contracté la maladie et au bientôt cent
mille familles auront été endeuillée un
an d'efforts pour tous d'angoise de
sacrifice de fierté aussi et d'actes
héroïques un an ou ensemble nous avons
résisté et a pris nous avons tenu
je vous l'avais dit dès le début nous
allions vivre avec le virus
et c'est bien cela alors si ce soir je
m'adresse à vous avec autant d'humilité
que de détermination
c'est pour vous dire que nous allons
tenir encore essayé de faire le point
sur l'épidémie
les prochaines étapes essayez de vous
dire que si nous restons unis solidaires
si nous savons durant les prochaines
semaines nous organiser alors nous
verrons le bout du tunnel et nous nous
retrouverons si je m'adresse à vous ce
soir c'est pour appeler à la
mobilisation de chacun pour ce mois
d'avril où beaucoup se joue
où en sommes-nous aujourd'hui après un
confinement dur lors de la première
vague au printemps 2020 puis ce qu'on a
appelé un confinement adapté lors de la
seconde vague à l'automne dernier nous
avons opté depuis le début de cette
année 2021 pour une réponse qui visaient
à freiner l'épidémie sans nous confiner
trois principes n'ont cessé de nous
guider
d'abord la sécurité vous protégez ne
jamais transiger sur la santé des
françaises et des français
permettre à chacun d'être soignés dans
les meilleures conditions
ensuite le deuxième principe c'est l'
équilibre
c'est à dire prendre en compte
les conséquences aussi des restrictions
sur nos enfants et leur éducation sur
l'économie la société la santé mentale
notamment des plus jeunes
veillez à ne pas pénaliser les
territoires où le virus circule - ou peu
et puis le troisième principe c'est la
responsabilité
c'est à dire faire confiance préférer
aux contraintes pour tous le civisme de
chacun pour avoir les bons comportements
face au virus
limiter ses contacts se faire tester aux
premiers symptômes et s'isoler lorsqu'on
est positif sécurité équilibre
responsabilité ce sont ces trois
principes qui nous ont conduits fin
janvier à privilégier le renforcement de
cette stratégie tester alerte et
protéger le couvre-feu la fermeture de
certains établissements sur leur
confinement général du pays
nous avons tous consenti des efforts
importants et le virus a continué de
circuler il circule encore aujourd'hui
fortement
mais là où beaucoup de nos voisins ont
décidé de confirmer
il ya maintenant quatre mois nos voisins
allemands par exemple là où nos amis
italiens en sont à leur quatrième
confinement nous avons aussi par ses
choix collectifs que nous avons fait
gagner des jours précieux de liberté des
semaines d'apprentissage pour nos
enfants
nous avons permis à des centaines de
milliers de travailleurs de garder la
tête hors de l'eau sans jamais perdre le
contrôle de l'épidémie
nous avons donc je le crois bien fait
croire en la responsabilité des français
ça n'est jamais un pari ces dernières
semaines nous faisons face à une
nouvelle donne
depuis au fond les premiers jours du
mois nous sommes entrés dans une course
de vitesse
d'un côté le déploiement de la
vaccination qui permet d'espérer
raisonnablement une sortie de crise et
je vais y revenir et de l'autre la
propagation dans toute l'europe d'une
nouvelle forme de virus
ce variant qui a été identifiée pour la
première fois chez nos voisins
britanniques qu'à la fin de l'année
dernière et qui en quelque sorte a fait
apparaître une épidémie dans l'épidémie
celle ci est plus étendue qu'au
printemps dernier ce qui fait qu'aucune
région métropolitaine n'est désormais
épargner et celle ci est aussi plus
dangereuse qu'à l'automne ce qui fait
que le virus est plus contagieux mais
aussi plus meurtriers les services de
réanimation ont à prendre en charge des
personnes en bonne santé qui ont
aujourd'hui 60 ans même cinquante ans
quelques uns parfois plus jeunes
retenez un chiffre 44 % des patients en
réanimation ont aujourd'hui moins de 65
ans face à ce double phénomène
nous avons décidé le 18 mars de prendre
pour près de 20 départements des
restrictions complémentaire au
couvre-feu national qui était déjà en
vigueur
deux semaines après la mise en place de
ces mesures les chiffres sont clairs oui
cette stratégie a eu des premiers effets
mais très clairement ces efforts restent
trop limité au moment où l'épidémie
accélère en quelque sorte
nous sommes en train de subir cette
accélération à cause du variant qui
risque de nous faire perdre contrôle
si nous ne bougeons pas nous devons donc
nous fixer pour les mois à venir un
nouveau cadre pour cela il ne faut
absolument pas céder à la panique
nous avons conservé la maîtrise de la
situation à l'hôpital
cette situation est dure beaucoup de
services sont surchargés mais nous n'en
avons pas perdu le contrôle nous ne
devons pas non plus aidé au déni ce
serait faux de dire que si nous ne
faisions rien les choses
s'amélioreraient d'elle-même non alors
nous nous placerions dans une situation
délicate de potentiel saturation de tout
le pays aussi pour continuer à protéger
la vie au présent c'est à dire les
malades et pour protéger la vie au futur
c'est à dire nos enfants nous devons
pour les mois à venir
fournir chacun un effort supplémentaire
c'est cela ce que je nous demandent
collectivement ce soir un effort des
soignants d'abord pour augmenter nos
capacités en réanimation
je veux ce soir salué à nouveau en votre
nom à tous l'action remarquable de nos
soignants et en particulier des équipes
de réanimation et de soins critiques qui
secteur public comme secteur privé
agissent main dans la main mutualisent
les équipes innove
non seulement pour soigner les 28
malades du cog vidal hôpital mais aussi
pour transformer des salles d'opération
en salle de réanimation pour assurer une
continuité de soins pour les patients
atteints de maladies graves comme le
cancer pour tous les moyens d'urgence
faire en sorte que tous les reçoivent
et que tous puissent avoir les soins
dont ils ont besoin
en mars dernier à cette heure ci nous
les applaudit sion n'oublions pas que
depuis un an
ils sont sur le pont sans relâche pour
augmenter encore le nombre de personnes
pouvant être accueillis en réanimation
centraux des programmes et ils sont et
seront appuyés dans les prochains jours
par des renforts supplémentaires le
nombre de lits en réanimation a déjà été
porté à 7 milles et je veux ici remercié
les étudiants en médecine les retraités
le service de santé des armées tous les
volontaires de la réserve sanitaire
tous sont mobilisés seront mobilisés de
manière accrue pour porter dans les
prochains jours notre capacité à un peu
plus de dix mille lits en particulier
aussi avec l'ouverture de nouvelles
capacités d'accueil dans certains
hôpitaux parisiens deuxième effort qui
nous concerne tous celui ci les règles
qui sont en vigueur dans les dix neuf
départements en vigilance renforcée ces
règles seront étendues à tout le
territoire métropolitain
dès ce samedi soir et pour quatre
semaines
si nous faisons ce choix qui ne concerne
pas du territoire d'outre-mer ce
territoire où le virus circule moins et
territoires qui d'ailleurs pour certains
ont fait de très gros efforts il ya
plusieurs semaines pour ralentir aussi
le virus de leur côté
si nous faisons ce choix touché tout le
territoire métropolitain
c'est parce que plus aucune région
métropolitaine mais aujourd'hui épargné
partout le virus circule vite de plus en
plus vite et par tous les
hospitalisations remonte et donc chacun
doit veiller non pas à s'enfermer
mais à limiter au maximum les contacts
les rencontres les moments de proximité
avec d'autres personnes très
concrètement ça veut dire que le
couvre-feu à 19 heures sera maintenue
par tous le télétravail qui est sans
doute la mesure la plus efficace
le télétravail sera systématisé et
j'appelle tous les travailleurs et tous
les employeurs à y avoir recours à
chaque fois qu'ils le peuvent
les commerces seront fermés sur tous les
territoires métropolitains
selon l'âge liste déjà défini dans les
dix-neuf départements aujourd'hui
concernant nos citoyens qui souhaitent
changer de région pour aller s'isoler
pourront le faire durant ce week-end de
pâques les françaises et les français de
l'étranger qui veulent rentrer en france
pourront aussi le faire à tout moment et
nous ferons tout pour faciliter les
trajets et le quotidien de nos
concitoyens travailleurs
transfrontaliers
alors certains militent et je le sais
pour le retour généralisé de
l'attestation comme en mars 2020 nous
n'avons pas retenu cette option parce
que l'irresponsabilité de quelques uns
ne doit pas ruiner les efforts de tous
les contrôles les sanctions seront
renforcés sur la voie publique pour
limiter les règles les rassemblements
parce que c'est là que le danger existe
et pour encadrer la consommation
d'alcool mais très clairement nous
faisons le choix de la confiance
nous faisons le choix de la
responsabilité et si je puis dire de la
respiration
l'attestation ne sera donc obligatoire
en journée que pour les déplacements au
delà de 10 km du domicile en cette
période qui est marquée par de
nombreuses fêtes religieuses
je sais aussi pouvoir compter sur vous
afin d'éviter comme nous avons su le
faire à noël les rassemblements privé
les fêtes avec les amis la famille les
proches
j'insiste vraiment sur ce point 7
lors de ces occasions que nous nous
contamine ont le plus il faut donc faire
cet effort
c'est un effort pour vous protéger et
pour protéger les autres s'agissant des
écoles et c'est quelque sorte le
troisième effort que nous allons faire
dans les semaines qui viennent
s'agissant des écoles nous devons tous
être conscients de nos devoirs vis-à-vis
de notre jeunesse nous pouvons nous
féliciter dans notre pays d'avoir
réouvert parmi les premiers nos écoles
au printemps dernier le 11 mais
rappelez-vous et de les avoir maintenus
ouverte depuis septembre 2020 faisons
partie des rares pays qui ont fait ce
choix alors même que nous avons été très
frappé par l'épidémie
nous l'avons fait en conscience parce
que nous croyons dans cet investissement
dans les jeunes enfants les adolescents
quelle éducation parce que c'est le
combat du siècle qui s'ouvre
car nos enfants ont besoin d'apprendre
d'être ensemble et nul ne sait dire les
conséquences profondes et durables d'une
fermeture prolongée des écoles qui
renforce les inégalités sociales comme
les inégalités de destin alors oui le
virus circule dans les établissements
scolaires mais pas plus qu'ailleurs et
l'éducation de nos enfants elle n'est
pas négociable l'école n'est pas
négociable
c'est pourquoi nous devons prendre nos
responsabilités oui il faut freiner le
virus aussi nous allons fermer durant
trois semaines les crèches les écoles
les collèges et des lycées
mais oui nous devons préserver
l'éducation et l'apprentissage
c'est pour cela que le calendrier
scolaire sera adapté pour ne pas laisser
nos enfants
seul et sans apprendre
de manière très concrète cela signifie
que la semaine prochaine
les cours pour les écoles collèges et
lycées se feront à la maison sauf comme
au printemps 2020 pour les enfants des
soignants et de quelques autres
professions qui seront accueillis de
même que les enfants en situation de
handicap qui doivent continuer à pouvoir
être accueillis dans le secteur médico
social
les deux semaines suivantes soit à
partir du 12 avril
la france entière quelle que soit la
zone de vacances sera placée en vacances
de printemps
la rentrée aura donc lieu pour tous le
26 avril physiquement pour les
maternelles et les primaires à distance
pour les collèges les lycées le 3 mai
les collégiens et les lycéens pourront
retrouver physiquement leur
établissement le cas échéant avec des
jauges adapté je sais croyez moi ce que
cette réorganisation implique de
changement profond pour les parents
d'élèves et pour les familles mais c'est
la solution la plus adaptée pour freiner
le virus tout en préservant l'éducation
et donc l'avenir de nos enfants
les étudiants quant à eux pourront pour
ceux qui le souhaitent continuer durant
toute cette période à se rendre à
l'université pour une journée de cours
par semaine
je veux ce soir en votre nom
remercier et saluer tous nos enseignants
et avec tous nos enseignants d'ailleurs
l'ensemble des personnels qui permettent
d'accueillir nos enfants dans les écoles
les collèges les lycées dans les
établissements spécialisés aussi car si
la france est un des pays à avoir le
moins fermer ses écoles comme je vous le
disais 42 semaines d'ouverture parfois
deux ou trois fois plus que certains de
nos voisins
c'est grâce à ave enfin comme depuis un
an
l'accompagnement économique et social
sera au rendez vous les parents qui
devront garder leur enfant et ne peuvent
pas télétravail et auront droit au
chômage partiel et pour les salariés les
commerçants les indépendants les
entrepreneurs et les entreprises
tous les dispositifs actuellement en
vigueur seront prolongées je sais
combien les efforts que je vous demande
sont difficiles je mesure ce qu'ils
emportent de conséquences pour notre
pays et pour vos vies et vous savez
aussi que nous avons tout fait pour
prendre ses décisions le plus tard
possible
et au moment où elle devenait
strictement nécessaire
c'est maintenant mais je tiens en même
temps à vous dire ce soir que grâce à la
vaccination
la sortie de crise se dessine enfin
parce que oui à cette heure vous êtes
déjà plus de huit millions et demi à
avoir reçu une première injection de
vaccin 3 millions à en avoir reçu 2 et
le vaccin est efficace il est au bout de
quinze jours après l'injection de la
deuxième dose la meilleure preuve
d'ailleurs de cette efficacité est dans
les chiffres
vous voyez à cet instant à votre écran
et dans la mortalité en particulier de
nos concitoyens de plus de 80 ans qui
ont la mortalité qui a très fortement
diminué
la meilleure preuve elle en est
d'ailleurs dans la situation des
résidents des maisons de retraite qui
vacciner à plus de 90% ont pu
progressivement reprendre une vie
normale
notre enjeu principal aujourd'hui c'est
donc d'accélérer encore et encore cette
mobilisation c'est celle évidemment du
gouvernement de nous tous et de tous les
soignants là encore avec une stratégie
claire d'abord continuer à avoir de plus
en plus de doses en accélérant nos
achats et surtout en produisant en
france et en europe
nous sommes pleinement mobilisés il ya
eu des retards
il y a eu des choses que nous avons
corrigé
je pourrais y revenir mais dans les
semaines à venir nous allons encore
accélérer le nombre de doses que nous
obtenons et nous allons progressivement
devenir le premier continent au monde en
termes de production de vaccins c'est
construire notre indépendance c'est
garantir que s'il faut des deux
suppléments
terre nous ne dépendrons plus des autres
c'est garantir aussi la production de
nouveaux vaccins
s'il y avait à nouveau à l'automne hiver
ou l'année prochaine des nouvelles
vaccination à prévoir ensuite c'est
vacciner le plus vite possible tous ceux
qui en ont le plus besoin c'est à dire
les plus âgés les plus fragiles ceux qui
ont le plus de risques de développer des
formes graves et j'assume totalement
cette priorité cet ordre que nous avons
donnée parce que c'est la garantie de
notre efficacité
c'est ainsi que nous pourrons soulager
plus rapidement l'hôpital
c'est ainsi que nous sauveront des vies
à partir de là nous mettons tous les
moyens pour vacciner vacciner vacciner
sans répit cent jours fériés le samedi
et le dimanche comme la semaine pour les
vaccins pfizer et moderna qui nécessite
des conditions de conservation
spécifiques
il y à 1700 centres de vaccination qui
ont ouvert notamment grâce à
l'engagement exemplaire de nos mères que
je veux ici remercier une fois encore
pour les vans pour les vaccins
astrazeneca et demain johnson & johnson
tous les médecins généralistes
pharmaciens infirmiers et infirmières
sont mobilisés au total 250 mille
professionnels médecins pharmaciens
sapeurs pompiers infirmiers vétérinaires
sont aujourd'hui prêts à contribuer à ce
grand effort national
si vous avez plus de 55 ans et être
atteint par exemple de diabète
d'hypertension ou de surpoids
vous pouvez aujourd'hui prendre rendez
vous auprès de votre médecin votre
infirmer votre pharmacien qui vous
vaccinera directement avec le vaccin
astrazeneca
cela a commencé depuis la semaine
dernière et nous allons accélérer à
mesure que les doses seront livrés les
1700 centres ouverts sont à disposition
pour se vacciner avec les vaccins pfizer
et moderna est aujourd'hui vacciner donc
tous nos concitoyens qui ont plus de 70
ans
les vaccinant les vaccinations sont en
cours et elles accélèrent par
je sais que beaucoup de nos aînés ont
essayé de prendre rendez vous pour se
faire vacciner ces dernières semaines
trop souvent sans succès et j'en suis
profondément désolé ce n'est pas
acceptable
c'est pourquoi j'ai demandé à
l'assurance maladie de mobiliser des
équipes pour y remédier depuis quelques
jours si vous avez plus de 75 ans vous
avez peut-être déjà reçu des appels car
l'ensemble des plus de 75 ans qui n'ont
pas réussi à obtenir un rendez-vous
seront appelés par nos services
pour pouvoir le lire fixé et en
parallèle un numéro spécial sera mis à
disposition pour prendre un rendez-vous
à partir du 16 avril
les premiers rendez vous seront accordés
aux personnes qui ont entre 60 et 70 ans
à partir du 15 mai les premiers
rendez-vous seront ouverts pour nos
concitoyens qui ont entre 50 et 60 ans
et à partir de la mi juin
les rendez-vous seront ouverts à
l'ensemble des françaises et des
français de moins de 50 ans une
stratégie de vaccination spécifique sera
par ailleurs prévu pour toutes les
professions les plus exposés en
particulier nos enseignants que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure mais aussi nos
forces de l'ordre et plusieurs autres
nous tiendrons l'objectif que je nous ai
fixé à savoir que d'ici à la fin de
l'été tous les français de plus de 18
ans qui le souhaitent pourront être
vaccinés
parce que c'est la clé pour renouer avec
la vie la clé pour ouvrir notre pays mes
chers compatriotes les efforts d'avril
d'une part et le déploiement de la
vaccination d'autre part c'est cette
taille qui va nous permettre de contenir
progressivement ce nouveau virus cette
taille qui va nous permettre à partir de
la mi mai deux commencé à rouvrir
progressivement le pays a retrouvé cette
culture qui nous a tant manqué à
retrouver les lieux de rencontre les
commerces à retrouver cet art de vivre à
la française que sont les restaurants
les cafés que nous aimons
je reviendrai vers vous prochainement
pour préciser un agenda de réouverture
et pour que chacun puisse aussi se
projeter avec plus de visibilité dans
les mois qui viennent dès la mi mai nous
recommencerons à ouvrir avec des règles
strictes certains lieux de culture nous
autoriserons sous conditions l'ouverture
de terrasses et nous allons bâtir entre
la mi mai et le début de l'été un
calendrier de réouverture progressive
pour la culture le sport les loisirs
l'événementiel nos cafés et restaurants
mais d'ici là je sais pouvoir compter
sur vous mes chers compatriotes je sais
qu'il ya beaucoup de lassitude de
fatigue
je sais qu'il ya aussi parfois de
l'énervement de l'emportement et c'est
bien normal
je sais qu'à chaque étape de cette
épidémie
nous pourrions nous dire que nous
aurions pu faire mieux
nous avons commis des erreurs tout cela
est vrai je sais une chose nous avons
tenu nous avons appris et nous nous
sommes à chaque fois améliorée alors oui
aujourd'hui pour le mois qui vient
il nous faut nous mauvais disait nous
mobiliser pour nos aînés et les plus
fragiles et nous mobiliser pour nos
enfants pour les protéger et leur
permettre de continuer à apprendre et
leur préparer le payer le continent le
monde auquel ils ont droit
nous mobiliser parce que le succès de ce
mois d'avril et de cette stratégie
dépend de chacun d'entre nous de notre
esprit de responsabilité
c'est ainsi que nous pourrons rebâtir ce
chemin d'espoir celui qui nous permettra
de retrouver progressivement une vie
normale celui qui nous permettra aussi
de tirer ensemble toutes les leçons de
cette épreuve mais nous tiendrons unis
et déterminé vive la république et vive
la france